in the entertainment is sure you see a
lot of very preachy people who are very
safe to Bay and you know what about the
ecology and this and then you know
they're getting on a private plane hi
I'm Zach Weissmuller with reason TV
we're here with Gavin pallone Hollywood
producer former agent director and now a
columnist for New York magazines vulture
calm some of his best-known projects
include panic room Gilmore Girls zombie
land and Curb Your Enthusiasm Gavin
thank you so much for joining us thank
you for inviting me a lot of productions
are leaving California or so we hear
should Californians be worried about
that I think what California should be
worried about I mean yes the the
business being destroyed but it's
actually being destroyed from outside in
my opinion it's about government
subsidies this never works I don't
really believe that protectionism of
markets works we don't have that many
industries that are our number one you
know we have this we have aerospace to
some extent we have elements of the
computer industry that are number one so
it's a valuable thing for us to be able
to actually make things that get
exported it's being eroded because of
protectionism and protectionism within
the country too so in state of
California you know we have the best
film community more things could be shot
here and then states like Louisiana or
New York or Connecticut or most states
they offer these incentives which is
basically just a tax rebate right it
creates a large inefficiency and
Michigan Institute a 42 percent I
believe is 42 percent tax incentive on
films and then huge numbers of film and
television went to Detroit and then a
new government came in and said look
we're bankrupting us why are we start
we're starting this whole new business
why are we why are we spending our money
on that versus health care or versus the
auto business which is already
established we have all these Auto
Workers
why don't we if we're gonna subsidize
something not that I say that they
should
why don't we subsidize manufacturing
because you know if someone's making a
car maybe they could be making planes
you're a self-described libertarian who
are your political influences what
thinkers or writers first authors would
go back to the my saying I'm a
self-described libertarian in reality I
don't define myself by those kinds of
terms sometimes when I'm talking to
people
I will say you know well I guess I'm
more libertarian than anything else in
the sense that I don't believe that
there's any one thing that works and I
don't believe I is a general concept but
not situationally I believe in freedom
and I believe in personal responsibility
okay I would like to be responsible for
myself I think that there should be
strong penalties for people who hurt
other people in some way but I should be
able to make those decisions for myself
and I think that I would love to see a
smaller government and I listen to
somebody like Ron Paul he'll talk about
eight things that I think are really
interesting and that I probably agree
with and then he'll talk about two
others that seem crazy to me you know
and I think that that's because nothing
really fits neatly into any particular
box and certainly my own views yeah fair
enough the function of government and
there's real value to having government
is to set up rules and penalties for for
the bad actors within society but I
think that the people who take care of
themselves and want to live their own
way and they should be allowed to do
that and and whatever the term is for
that if that's libertarian or that's
just you know Gavin ISM or whatever you
know that's how I feel like it should be
the perception is that most people in
Hollywood do not agree with that and are
very liberal is first of all is that
your experience people in Hollywood are
just hypocrites feel everywhere
hypocrites yes so in the entertainment
issue you see a lot of very preachy
people who are very save the bay and you
know what about the ecology and this and
then you know they're getting on a
private plane and they're very liberal
about big government and wanting a lot
of social services but yet they take
advantage of everything that they
possibly can to pay less in taxes they
want to affect a certain kind of persona
and so you see much more of that kind of
like big movie star driving around in a
Prius and then but getting picked up in
the limo and taken to the helicopter
which flies to the private plane which
lands in the private Airport and getting
on the helicopter and then the limo from
the helicopter pad to the gigantic suite
at the Four Seasons do you think that
the way that the business is structured
do you think there are flaws within the
the business model for instance the
studio model yes
I think that there are a lot of flaws I
think there's just a lot of waste and
bad management and I think it really
still needs to change it's come a long
way it's the same thing as like you look
at our government and we continue to
pile on debt and overspend and then
there's these examples which we discount
like Greece or Spain or Italy I mean
with Spain in Italy or large large
countries and they have their own
mentality about how much debt that were
going to take on I don't know why our
government and our people can't start to
see how we can't keep spending like this
otherwise we can possibly down the road
end up in that same situation you know
you know when I look at the movie in
television business why can't they see
that there they could easily end up like
the record business which is really a
sliver of what it was I mean where does
that come from what why do you think
that that this sort of culture has
arisen in in Hollywood there's a lot of
reasons one reason was that when the
business started out it was really just
people you know you had the Warner
Brothers they had the freedom to handle
it like their own little personal
kingdoms and do whatever they want the
business has matured and technology
starts to necessitate that you can't
treat everything that way because it's
much more egalitarian now there's a lot
of forms of entertainment that people
can go to
I still see movie studios wasting huge
amounts of money on overhead paying too
much for movie stars
if movie stars mean anything today the
entertainment industry is also heavily
unionized how does that play into the
equation if at all
in general I'm pretty negative about
unions I don't need I don't really
believe in black and white in any kind
of context I'm certainly open to the
idea that in some contexts certain
people probably could use collective
bargaining and it could be very valuable
for them especially when safety issues
and health issues are involved when I
look at the entertainment industry and
especially the unions that represent
people who are the most advantage like
the Writers Guild or the Directors Guild
or there's these things called the
producers guild is so ridiculous to me
and what are they really doing you know
they're protecting people's credits you
know we were shooting on my television
show we had a we the show takes place in
New York within the context the show but
we shoot it here
and then we had written an episode where
characters were going to Beverly Hills
so this seemed like a great opportunity
for us because we could shoot something
here as opposed to having to go to New
York which we do one or two times a year
and just shoot little pieces I wasn't
able to work it out because it was just
too costly not only because of the
permit fees and how people treat you in
terms of locations but just like you'd
have you are mandated by the unions to
have a larger number of people working
even if you don't need them and so that
created a situation where we were not
able to realize on screen what I wanted
to do you face resistance for kind of
swimming against the tide no you know I
say a lot of things that I know other
people like I'll say something in public
or around people and people will say
something to me like I agree with you
but I would never say that or or this
this thing or in the entertainment issue
is on I'm gonna tell you something and
if anybody and if you repeat it and it
gets back to me I'll deny it like kind
of a [ __ ] or you I'll deny what I say
it's like I there's so much of that that
goes on that it's really pathetic and it
shows how pathetic people are there is
this illusion of retribution in the
entertainment industry you can say what
you want and you can protect yourself
and you can be somewhat confrontational
when you feel like you need to be
because there just really isn't that
kind of retribution if you're Mel Gibson
and you do something you do things that
are really just terrible really horrible
yeah some people are gonna probably shy
away from you but the probably shy away
from because the public's gonna shy away
from you you know but I think if you're
Gavin pallone and you just you know
someone you're at a party or you're
being interviewed I've been interviewed
on television and I said look I just
think our policy towards Israel is
absolutely inconsistent with our policy
towards other countries there are
nuclear power and then we try to get
Pakistan or North Korea to give up their
nukes or we take we have sanctions
against Iran for developing a nuclear
nuclear weapons and then Israel has 200
nuclear weapons what is it that doesn't
make any sense why are we doing this and
then I point out it's because small
groups of people who are pro-israel you
know are giving huge amounts of money to
our corrupt legislators and you know you
say that and then what happens then you
wait no people still make my movies last
question what can people look forward to
coming
the mind of Gavin pallone I have a few
more projects and you know movies and TV
shows and things that are that are kind
of brewing but you know overall what I
think I'd like to do more is be able to
write or commentate on a wider range of
subjects so right now this thing with
New York Magazine and vulture has been
going very well I've been developing a
little more of a following and then so I
think in the future I'd just like to do
more writing and be able to write about
some of the things that we just talked
about thank you so much for joining us
appreciate of you to have anything
thanks for reason TV I'm Zack
Weissmuller